[Music]  my name is ianni sikonoma i'm from  greece and i speak 32 languages russian  portuguese norwegian turkish hungarian  czech police ayannas is what we call a  hyper polyglot  it means he can speak a lot of languages  by the time i was 20 i'd already learned  some  15 languages and  when i moved to brussels and started my  career at the eu institutions i added  more official eu languages see the thing  is i honest he's a quick learner  [Music]  this doesn't happen by just sitting at  home and studying though  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  the world is a big place with different  cultures and yes different languages it  left me living in northern spraken in  italian and marine ental i speak to my  husband in polish because he's polish i  dream in all kinds of languages  parmituzzi  [Music]  before we go if anyone knows it's you  what is the most complicated language to  learn  mandarin  mystery solved